rebecca bonsoir bonsoir alors une figure
très connue serge et jane ya une autre
j'étais un autre majeur nu plusieurs
rapports il ya eu en tout cas autour de
serge reggiani à peu près dix ans fait
par des artistes français cela ces
examens le boulet une autre grande
vedette donc isabelle le boulet qui
décide de lui rendre hommage peut-être à
l'occasion du dixième anniversaire de
son décès d'ailleurs il y aura un
spectacle aux francofolies merci serge
reggiani le même titre que l'album et ça
sera présenté en clôture des francos le
vainqueur on va écouter un premier puck
de presque rien
dix années de moi
je te dis
je problème
et je te prennent par la main
pourtant mené à sa jambe
d'offrir un autre café crème
elles sont toutes les chansons connues
moi j'aime beaucoup bercée depuis je
suis tout petit j'étais pas sûr mais on
va écouter si vous le voulez bien
l'italie l'armé préférée
ça vous donne une bonne idée c'est moi
c'est l'italien est ce qu'il y a
quelqu'un est ce qu'il y a quelques unes
dc j'entends le chien et si tu n'es pas
mort tu ouvres mois sans rancune
le temps le tissu monde
ou tu m'arrive s à la taille
ça me semble encore tout à l'heure mais
déjà tu marivaux coeur thébaux
salzgitter vous êtes convaincu d'en haut
oui oui non mais c'est vrai que ça rend
nostalgique mais très beau les textes
absolument comme des petits films
georges moustaki entre on l'avait vu en
conférant de ces derniers caf à montréal
y avait plus là il avait du mal à
prononcer les paroles de sa musique
et c'était tout aussi 100 m et puis
là-bas isabelle boulay c'est une grande
interprète c'est un album qui a été
coréalisé par benjamin biolay proches
collaborateurs et fait les bébés c'est
assez étonnant est qu'il adviendrait
toujours un peu du pareil au même et
c'est pour vérifier les billets partout
on va parler avec je m'écoutais je suis
content mais avouez avec isabelle boulay
s'est toujours raffiné élégant de grande
qualité
je vous vois qu'on avoue très bien au
basket je n'ai hélas les black keys les
black keys un duo blues au rock
originaire de l'ohio
vraiment ils ont connu un succès tardif
ces deux hommes une chanson vous avez
peut-être beaucoup entendu taille 9 dans
des pubs de subaru dans des pulls de mon
souci
oh non
d'où ça ne fait pas sans plus à 2 watts
crête ce parce que c'était également un
duo batterie guitare mais cette fois ci
on a changé un petit peu la formule
c'est déjà un huitième album après
plusieurs grammys et il ya un petit peu
plus de psychédélisme et du falsetto
congé à bord les voix d'hommes très très
tendue ça donne ça
t
m
je vous
je ne sais pas
on
c'est le son d'un quai de file vous
trouvez vous n'êtes pas le seul à penser
ça mais cet album est plus mélodique et
beaucoup de gros ventre bref moi je
trouve ça très efficace j'aime beaucoup
l'accusent les black keys boulot oui
c'est tout cas on va se laisser avec
michael jackson
ça fait déjà cinq ans qu'il est décédé
huchon au presque et deuxième album
posthume y en a qui vont dire que c'est
une expérience un petit peu un exercice
mercantile son indice qui s'appelle
escape xk et il ya des chansons tirées
de diverses époques 10 missions se
retrouve la semaine prochaine
à
alors
yuko